on a mis une caméra dans la loge
maquillage et on a regardé tout ce qui
s'est passé pour le dit on à nouveau
personnage qui s'appelle pukki qui est
en régie pour qui la peau cave pukki non
ça bonsoir pour qui ça va bien c'est
clinker est ce que c'est que ce délire
non je suis pas inquiet il ya des
dossiers sur moi aussi
vous vivez à merde qu'est le premier
dossier pukki alors le premier dossier
va vous le savez en fait ça démarre avec
votre règle d'or vous avez tout de suite
marquer votre territoire vous avez
envoyé un règlement intérieur à tous les
chroniqueurs par texto bien sûr oui
c'est vrai avant le début de la saison
oui exactement avec une règle vraiment
fondamental voilà a pas de portable sur
le plateau non non non c'était la règle
numéro 8 je crois voilà exactement la
règle numéro un alors elle a été
respectée et bien j'ai envie de vous
dire je vous laisse découvrir tout ça
c'est parti cette jeune dame on peut
découvrir seul ou qui alors je ne sais
pas si on peut découvrir
moi j'ai les images assez pas et ça
arrive
je voulais vous dire un truc là vous
oubliez les caméras vous oubliez tous je
vous dis un truc je ne veux plus de
portables dans l'émission pas mais je
vous dis maintenant on peut voir si la
règle a été respectée
bien évidemment c'est que vous me
connaissez pas encore mais je vais pas
tarder calmez-vous je suis neutre alors
mis autour de cette table bien sûr que
vous écoute
ben oui tout le monde est d'accord avec
vous tout le monde respecte les
consignes vous êtes le maître après tout
donc c'est parti la première affaire du
téléphone gates c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour l'instant la règle n'a pas été du
tout respectée pour qui alors absolument
pas malheur chez certains on voit bien
qu'il ya une culpabilité alors que pour
d'autres il se cache et de vous c'est
pas vraiment la priorité
regardez les croquer
à croquer jimmy dans ces combats cette
pomme avec celle de personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'euro c'est normal ça alors j'sais pas
moi j'avais que ce soit très clair
j'avais compris la règle aucun portable
pendant l'émission lorsqu'on est à
l'antenne star le cas ici rien au quart
temps les plus la preuve en est c'est
d'ailleurs pendant l'émission fallait
bien pousser en revanche c'est déjà pas
mal d'ailleurs
oui messieurs de leurs maux vous
expliquez moi comme vous car là encore
abadie zone de leurs mots c'est toujours
le premier donc pour balancer des
copains ya du monde
même quand on le fait soi même en garde
il ya une info qui est sorti c'est une
amérique en quoi encore castaldi qui a
son téléphone
pour toute dénonciation des spectateurs
pour ce qu on a d'autres choses assure
qu'on ad'autres choses vous avez pu par
exemple et bien découvrir très vite pas
vous mais mais si vous vous vous bien
sûr que si vous j'ai les images devant
moi alors ça va être très très simple je
vais confier quoi j'ai découvert que
vous étiez pas le dernier vous étiez
même le pire le plus fou de la bande
et oui c'est vous cyril de très très
loin on découvre ça fait quoi
mettez vos places bordel de merde
[Musique]
soit
j'ai la patate a fait tâche dans ton ta
des patates
tantôt il ya des patates bof bof bof bof
bof wang sont pas qu une partie du sel
s'est copieusement
moi j'ai trop mal et autres monstres les
chéris j'ai profité de la pub pour voir
qui peut tout ce qu'on a à faire pendant
l'émission
avant lui qui nous enjoignent les
matériaux 37 mm p xxl et on est en
direct et on a une nouvelle intervenants
qui s'appelle pukki caf tous et je vous
le dis on a mis une caméra dans la loge
des chroniqueurs et vous verrez j'ai
même pas vu les images moi j'ai pas
voulu les voir trop violent par ici pour
qui on a d'autres choses pourront bien
sûr il y en a toujours un qui est là
pour vous l'homme de l'ombre
nous y de latran secret n'en fais jamais
des caisses il est connu sous le nom du
fayot le lèche cul le lambi biba bien
évidemment la caisse qui la famille est
fébrile et toujours prêt à vous suivre
on regarde un magnifique
oui ces enfants est ce encore de vos
idées j'imagine la création du mec
travaillé cet été merci jean michel
mercier crac crac badaboum tagada
souffre tour
excellent
[Applaudissements]
on s'est régalé
[Musique]
c'est valverde même si vous n'aimez pas
d'amitié dans d'écouté pour les autres
allez on a d'autres images ma peau qui
bien sûr il ya d'autres aussi qui font
de gaffes des très très grosse gaffe
pendant les émissions alors en plus on
avait tout bien organisé pour que ça
fasse une petite surprise mais mais bon
il ya eu kelly coucou kelly a de la
mémoire
ça s'est passé sur le prime avec big flo
et oli on a eu une petite surprise mais
pas tout gâcher non c'est quoi allez-y
on va découvrir sa bastille
qui se cache dans le rideau blanc
[Applaudissements]
m
alors eh ben c'est pas la fin de secret
mais la prochaine fois elle restera chez
elle pour les proches aidants bon
j'adore ni folie mais non on a d'autres
choses beaucoup bien sûr la vraie vraie
vraie poucave dont c'est vraiment le
métier
1 le bon petit arbre sans scrupules qui
aiment balancer des vannes sur ses
camarades
c'est bien sûr mathieu allez on se fait
plaisir allez c'est parti
non non non non tu as tu rentres
ludivine on va libérer à ludivine qui la
travaille dans un club de strip tease
comment ça va
on commence avec 100 boyard sur france 2
qu a fêté ses 30 ans chez que maxime qui
n'y a participé à fort boyard
pardon mais quand on est rendu invité
maxime guinée j'ai rien contre lui mais
leur activité max et jean il saisit ont
fait pas qui c'est elles savent que tu
regardes ça la lutte et principale
d'accès égalité devant ta télé tous ceux
qui s'agitent et croient qui fait rire
qui a préféré de ces luttes tu parles
forcément des heures le vendredi moi je
suis leader du lundi au jour à la
lumière
brasserie divine c'est vrai les villes
qui est une amie un montage bien sûr
alors si l'on vous connaissez danseurs
avec votre petit surnom l'animal comme
un fan tous vous avez affectueusement
attribués eh bien on a découvert un
nouveau talent cette fois oui belge jean
michel chaillou va pas dire le contraire
cyril chanteur au maire découvre ça les
[Musique]
passionnés mot sur pas très tôt elle est
restée plantée à temps que je demande
pardon
[Musique]
avant j'ai jamais j'ai vraiment très
très très malade
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez comme ça vous pensez quoi de
vous je ne cache pas sa peur je ne
connais pas cette personne tu te kiffe
ou pas j'éprouve tient un petit grain de
bois pour du vibrato oui effectivement
mais j'ai du mal quand même de bonnes
minutes à reconnaître les titres que
vous étiez en train de charger encore
cela que je la verrais tu les verras
c'est la patronne des patronnes paraît
que c'est là que les narines du patron
on peut rien faire contre elle elle va
nous points lundi toute l'année mais un
peu en plus il ya un syrie qui connaît
bien les paroles en français mais il ya
le ciri polyglotte aussi vous maîtrisez
aussi les paroles dans toutes les
langues c'est fabuleux
ouais c'est vrai allez on découvre sa
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
l'ex je dors
mais la donne a choisi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit que de tels engins on a concernant
magath dont quatre étaient pas qui tu as
dis pas que ta gueule ou pas
[Applaudissements]
annoncé par bateau qui connaît le talent
non salées vous sentez très très bien
battus et merci juste et comme vous êtes
un beau nom mais je pense vraiment qu'il
faudra démarrer par une première partie
de deux vous devrez faire quelque chose
genre qui genre une partie de rihanna
oui j'ai peur que les caissiers vous
songez vraiment pourquoi pas faire un
album
oui si c'est un album à l'époque est
alors l'heure est grave
quoi j'ai une grande révélation vous
faire vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
donc c'est un peu gâchée mais reste
quand même pas le moins grande et bien
j'ai cache effectivement des vidéos j'ai
cacher des caméras partout partout et
surtout dans les linges sales a cédé au
lobby dont vos têtes à la casse et des
caméras dans les loges dans la loge
chroniqueurs oui on va commencer
crescendo avec les conseils des anciens
petits nouveaux un pour rentrer dans
cette belle 7,6 grande famille soudée
les conseils de la taulière donné j'ai
des ruelles
la connaissance qui prennent tous ces
subventions qui ferait toucher un mot à
la mode c'est quand ils sont cela il
faut laisser façonner ses enfants j'ai
fait les comptes des personnes chez les
comités mais ni dépens des combes et une
fois avec lui c'est d'être une idée
vraiment pas le jour 4 non ma près des
fossés du direct que vous allez les
côtés du continent oui mais après ça se
trouve je dis ça mais bel et bien sûr
mon cédric 6r à vous nos théâtres on va
faire le show thomas vue de décider s'il
faut laisser faire son petit spectacle
on règlera saladier le petit thomas
ouais je lui fais un autre bien sûr
renouveler les conseils des petits
nouveaux mais le mieux c'est quand ça
vient du taulier ce fait le président
l'âme de tp
jean mimi bien sûr
[Rires]
voilà sur la mort sous tension
sur les sujets où j'ai pas de stress
scenarii d'accord j'ai envie tu avait
bloqué le numéro de la bible oui mais
c'est notre travail mais c'est énorme et
nous rejoignent et un cerveau soeur on a
autre chose pour bien sûr à la première
on a eu pour notre plus grand plaisir
kelly agathe les meilleurs ennemis qui
se sont enfin réconciliés c'est
objectivement spectaculaire on regarde
on sera quand même heureux au revoir ça
envoie sus
mal
[Musique]
ça c'était ça c'était le prénom voit que
la catalogne avec lui autant dans sa
garde à vue ça mais ça garde si on est
d'accord plus à rallier pas d'aller
partout à l'air soumises agréablement
aussi oui mais agathe elle y va on aille
à kelly est très joli jeu c'est normal
alors alors c'était magnifique la belle
réconciliation j'étais mûr là là j'avais
les larmes aux yeux j'ai failli pleurer
enfin c'est beau à l'antenne parce que
en loge basse c'est autre chose
les sags at on découvert d'un euro peut
enfin conscients qu'ils cherchent ils
plus à mon frère parce qu'elle a tenue
place
[Musique]
mais bon c'est moche c'est mme chabot
c'est moche
quelle mère religieux les jolies au
kenya les déçus mais mais câline se ne
fait pas la choqué qu'il y ait une
facile voilà effectivement je te connais
bien la kelly et bercy s'est passé pas
mal non plus hein on regarde oui on
regarde les fonctions loges
ou tu dis partout moi mais non ouais
c'est insupportable logique humaine
entre les 12 premiers fruits
j'étais pas mal actuel c'était important
et des coûts de ckoi elle était belle
avec qualité des fringues ardentes
abbaoui ben oui pas ce sujet à des
médias avaient trouvé leur nombre à
trouver ton bonheur sur mon compte
installer des analyses qui avait coûté
oui on va en avoir une parce que j'ai
encore sous le coup d'un parce qu'on est
un
on est à un partout alors oui l'histoire
j'ai une histoire super sympa c'est le
mystère de la banane acp c'est quoi ça
savez de quoi je veux parler
non elle vaut le détour vraiment c'est
quoi la balade avec vous allez découvrir
tout ça partie
[Musique]
pas paniquer devant ses fans
ouais alors jusque là tout va bien
j'aurai la joie bien il n'ya rien à voir
non non non mais en fait c'est pas
choquant pour lui mais c'est choquant
pour quelqu'un d'autre on regarde c'est
la honte c'est la honte à la raison
ludivine mais le pire est à venir c'est
sans compter la mauvaise foi de jean
michel parent c'est parti mon kiki
les assistants personnels
s
[Applaudissements]